el sistema europeo de información sobre
incendios forestales ha reportado que en
italia más de 100 mil hectáreas han sido
arrasadas por los incendios durante este
verano esto sería el equivalente a unos
140 mil campos de fútbol también
lamentablemente las autoridades informan
que por lo menos 20 millones de animales
habrían perdido la vida durante estos
incendios los más graves y fuertes en
italia de hecho la el sistema de
información meteorológica ayer calculó
que en la población de floridian
siracusa la temperatura llegó a los
cuarenta y 8.8 grados un récord en
europa se espera que para las próximas
semanas toda la región de sicilia y el
sur de italia pueda estar sobre los 40
grados lo que ha generado pues las
alertas acerca de más incendios sin duda
un verano que en italia se recordara
amargamente